Hello there. As-salamu alaykum, habibi.
Wa alaykumu s-salam. Yeah, um the
Trinity brother is um
it's uh
when you when you have a strong belief,
it's okay. Uh you you can follow that,
but if you go to the logical aspect of
the Trinity, it doesn't makes any sense
because when the Father in the heaven
exists and and the God on and Jesus is
God on Earth, so when you think
logically, we have two gods because the
God on Earth is talking to the God on on
in the heaven. He is always talking to
him to the Father. That's not two gods.
That's just two persons. Or two persons,
sorry. But the thing is if you follow
your your your your belief, yeah, that
uh God has crucified himself, yeah, on
the cross. It is it is present, yes?
It's a present for you for us for the
for mankind. But from who comes the
present, brother? It comes from the
Father. The Father present Jesus for us.
So the present is come from the Father.
So The present you said the the present?
Yeah, Jesus. Jesus is he's offering
himself, but Okay.
Who has given who has given Jesus the
the the
Who has given Jesus um
a commandment to offer himself? It's not
from himself. The Father has given the
offer this offer Jesus to mankind to
offer himself, yes? Okay. But why why
you pray to Jesus? You must pray to the
Father who has offered Jesus Because for
mankind. Because Jesus offered himself
and is one in essence with the Father
and is worthy of the same honor that the
Father is according to him. He says that
you are to honor the Son the same way
that you honor the Father, which is
through worship, so that's why.
in the same time, you cannot honor two.
So if you honor Jesus, you don't honor
the Father in the same time. It's
But but Jesus says honor the Son the
same way we honor the Father. And if we
don't honor the Son, then we don't honor
the Father who sent him. So we do honor
them both. Yes, but Jesus only teach you
how to honor the Father. That's the only
that's the only message from Jesus to
mankind.
he says the same honor that we give to
the Father, we have to give to the Son.
The same exact honor. That's what he
says. Yeah, he show you how to honor how
to honor the Father because we are we
don't know anything, brother. We we must
follow the scriptures. We we must follow
the the the intelligence God give to us.
It's you make it a difficult. How do you
How do you honor the Father? The Father
is God. For me is the creator. The there
is one God.
Yeah. How do How do we honor him? If we
follow his his commitments, his all the
law and order. All right, we follow his
law and order. What else? How else do we
honor him? With um
when we pray we follow When we follow
when we live when we when we when we
yes, pray. When we follow what he's what
he's teaching
we said that first. So we follow his
teachings, his laws and commandments. We
pray to him, right? We worship him,
right? Yes. These are ways that we honor
the Father, right? Jesus Jesus says the
same way that you honor the Father, you
honor the Son. So we are to obey the
Son's laws and commands. We are to pray
to the Son. And we are to worship the
Son. That's how we honor the Father, so
we have to honor the Son the same way.
Okay. Yep. It's beautiful. The Son of
God is worthy of our honor and worship
and our adoration.
It's not far It's not far from us,
brother. Really, it's not far. It's
right there. It's It's right there, man.
It's close.
Today you Brother, today you are
smarter. You are smarter than your
church fathers. I know it is.
history You are very uh smart and I I
like you. I like you I I I feel you're
good You have a very good If you like
me, bro, re- read read Justin Martyr or
leader Nayas or somebody. They are I'm
not even in the same sphere when it
comes to knowledge and wisdom as them.
Nowhere near, bro. You know in the Quran
God offers you something very big. You
know the first when he say to you, "Oh
people of the scriptures, when you
return to me, I will
uh
cancel all your bad things and change it
to good ones and put you on the highest
level of paradise." You know, highest
level? It means you are with the
prophets in the highest level of That's
is your the promise from God to you,
brother. No, the promise the promise I
and I hope That's sometimes That's not
the promise. That's not the promise to
me, man. The promise of Allah to me, I'm
a Christian. Allah promised me hellfire
and that I'm the worst of creatures.
That's what he says about me. That's his
promise.
No, when why you read these verses? Why
you You are very smart Why
You're asking why do I read those
verses? Yes. Yes. Because because it's
because it's in the Quran and it and it
talks about me. It talks about me as a
Christian.
I'm not not not all Christians. God
difference. It's a big difference. Yeah,
those those who those who dis-
Yeah, those who disbelieve. Those who
disbelieve among the Christians and the
Jews. So because Because because I I
disbelieve in Islam and I can't accept I
can't accept it. I have to I believe in
the Son of God.
it's it's it's just a question of time,
God logic. You are very smart guy and
you have a good heart. I know
I'm too smart to join Islam, man. That's
the thing. My heart is too good
and my mind is too smart.
will be a big scholar in Islam. I mean I
already am. I'm already a big scholar in
Islam. Akhi, wallah, because you
interpret some verses some
something of Quran, I think you are
better than some scholars today. I am.
How you
How you understand that and how you read
it, I think mashallah, really. And I I
pray to God God logic. It's I for me
it's just a personal meaning. Habibi,
it's just a question of time that you
will be a very big scholar in some
inshallah. Yeah, in time in time I'll be
a big scholar in Islam, bigger than what
I am, but you know, because of that and
my true knowledge that I will have and
the genuineness of my heart, I will
never be able to join Islam because I
know that it's not true. It rejects and
denies the true character of Christ and
the message of God. It denies it. That's
what I do this for, brother. I do this
for people like you and others who can
possibly come to the truth. Yeah. As I
said before, Allahu alam. You don't know
what's happening in the future, brother.
it's it's Yahweh who It's
brother, it's it's It's not Allahu alam.
It's Yahweh who alam. Yahweh who alam.
Uh Yahweh knows best. Yahweh Yahweh is a
Semitic. You must understand the Semitic
language.
He's calling you. He already called me
and he got me. He got me in his grasp,
man.
He's calling you also. He already got
me. He already got me. I believe in
that. Yeah, inshallah. As-salamu
alaykum, my brother. Wa alaykumu
s-salam, man. Take care.
Oh, man. Some of these guys are really
really nice. You know, they generally
believe in what they believe and they
really want you to join them. It's
unfortunate, but like you know, these
nice people.